sie sind großartig zu tun
der auftrag wurde gerade per mail
bestätigt was mag ja wahnsinn
bis morgen alex lucas wir haben den
auftrag für das wird das größte was alex
evans bislang organisiert registriere
das heißt der vertrag muss natürlich
noch aufgesetzt und unterzeichnet werden
aber dann können wir sofort
unterschriften gedacht habe ich total
vergessen wenn ich dich nicht hätte gute
arbeit begann wie immer sehr gern wollen
wir zusammen ich meine georgiers
erfolgten muss gefeiert werden
hältst du zeit
und tschüss momentan ist jetzt noch raus
klar die nacht ist noch jung
es ist nach mitternacht wer kommt denn
hier gerade aus der kneipe du ich komme
du willst gehen das ist der punkt
außerdem bin ich dein großer bruder
bitte jetzt nicht diese beschützer
nummer abziehen das sich an die papa ich
bin schließlich volljährig ja aber du
wolltest hier wohnen und trage ich die
verantwortung
du kannst nicht jede nacht durchmachen
denn papa bleiben können der papa hätte
dir gar nicht erlaubt noch so spät raus
zu gehen
vor allem nicht mit so einem lippenstift
einig mit seinem leben stift
ein cooler versorgung soll das kochen
wir haben heute ein interview gegeben
für die deutsche welle das wird morgen
gezeigt du musst es dir ansehen und
stell dir vor wir wollen demnächst einen
mitschnitt von einem unserer giggs
machen geil oder ich freue mich für dich
ich quatsche nur bedingt wie war dein
tag der termin in bonn
ich habe sagt schon nein im gegenteil
wir haben den auftrag bekommen unsere
auftraggeber das mag
zloty wir müssen miteinander werden
weißt du mir aus
diese sollte ich locker ich weiß
bescheid
ich habe den schwangerschaftstest
cuisine flächen schwangerschaft hessen
kommen jetzt nicht so welchen
schwangerschaftstest
wo hast du ihn gefunden den er hat ihn
in ihrem kulturbeutel gefunden
lena lena sie hat ihn gefunden
er kann hier nur von dir sein na klar
nach dem was sie alles mit euren eltern
durchgemacht hat kein wunder hat es
damit zu tun was denkst du dir euer
vater erst darauf reagiert dass sie
schwanger ist
natürlich liebt sie